so we're given this function f of X
equals 2x squared plus 4x minus 16 and
we want to find the average rate of
change from x1 equals negative 3 to x 2
equals 2 so what exactly does that mean
average rate of change when you see the
phrase average rate of change what that
really refers to is the slope and I
graph this particular function right
here just to illustrate you don't have
to do this for these problems but just
to show you that see the average rate of
change of the slope you know that for
example here the slope is negative here
it's 0 here it's positive you can see
that the slope is constantly changing
depending on where you're at on this
particular graph but what we're looking
at is between these two points so like
when X is negative 3 this point 2 when x
equals 2 this point what's the average
rate of change between these two points
meaning what's the slope of that line
what we need to do though in order to
find the slope which remember is this
formula here y2 minus y1 over x2 minus
x1 we need to find the Y values so let's
go ahead and put negative 3 in and 2 in
and see what those Y values are so this
will be negative 3 comma let's see this
is 9 times 2 is 18 minus 12 which is 6
minus 16 is negative 10 and if we put 2
in for X we get 2 squared is 4 times 2
is 8 plus another 8 which is 16 minus 16
is 0 so we've got our two points now
let's go ahead and put it into our slope
formula so this is going to be negative
10 minus 0 I'm just subtracting the
y-values divided by negative 3 minus 2
which equals negative 10 over negative 5
which equals 2 and that's the slope of
this line that's the average rate of
change now when you're doing this be
careful about the order y2 minus y1 over
x2 minus x1 or you can do it the other
way zero minus negative 10 over 2 minus
negative 3 but you want to stay
consistent you want to change the order
Midway otherwise you're going to get the
wrong slope so I hope this helped you
understand how to find average rate of
change subscribe to the channel and
check out more math videos on my Mario's
math to your YouTube channel and I'll
see you in the next video